as with any comic book movie the suicide
squad features some comic book deep cuts
a few of these are villains with larger
backstories a couple have more nuance
than it's shown and one is a big time
important cameo here's how these
characters mean more than you realize
calendar man played by sean gunn shows
up as a prisoner who mocks polkadot man
given the events of the suicide squad a
little comic's know-how shows that this
foreshadows polkadot man's evolution
over the movie calendar man's calling
card is that he's obsessed with
calendars and dates often planning his
crimes on days of specific significance
there's no way or need to sugarcoat this
that is an extremely stupid gimmick for
a villain even among batman's rogue's
gallery which includes a man who loves
riddles he may represent the nader or at
least he represented that nader until
the batman's story the long halloween
which finds batman tracking down a
mysterious killer who's murdering a new
victim every month and the only person
who knows the killer's identity is
calendar man in a role often compared to
that of hannibal lecter and silence of
the lambs calendar man drops hints from
a cell in arkham asylum much like the
way the long halloween proved calendar
man's worth the suicide squad is the
vehicle that elevates polka dot man
beyond joke status gun included polka
dot man after googling dumbest super
villain of all time and proceeded to
give the formerly maligned villain a
compelling backstory calendar man is
laughing at what he once was
i'm a superhero
double down played by jared leland gore
joins calendar man in his mockery of
polkadot man unlike calendar man however
double down has never had a reinvention
or reintroduction and has remained a
throwaway gimmick villain whether gun
wanted another goofy villain to laugh a
polka dot man or is just setting up a
potential future task force x-member is
hard to say but his goofiness is worth
acknowledging double down and his
limited appearances has largely been a
villain who battles the flash he was a
con man and semi-professional gambler
because nothing makes for a good villain
origin like three-card monty he
encountered a cursed deck of cards which
gave him his powers all of which are
weird card gimmicks most of which
involve throwing them listen we promised
interesting we didn't promise splashed
out
dr fitzgibbon is one of the doctors
working for argus among his many duties
are inserting the nanite bombs that act
as waller's insurance into the skulls of
task force x members the character is
only glimpsed briefly but the role
itself isn't important rather it's the
person playing him jonas strander the
man responsible for some of the best and
most important suicide squad comics gunn
noted on twitter that ostrander is a
former actor which made the role easier
ghana's also on record saying that
ostrander's suicide squad is the biggest
influence on the film along with
aldrich's the dirty dozen we had a huge
poster of this in our production office
while shooting
johnny conomos played by comedian steve
agee is the warden of bel rev it's a
minor role he shows up long enough to
prove he's competent at what he does and
that he hates peacemaker he has a
similar role in the comics debuting in
suicide squad number one 1987 with the
same job and has shown up two or three
times each decade since the end of
ostrander's run there's admittedly not a
ton of depth to his character but it's
not his character that's important
rather it's aeg himself who pulls double
duty in this movie he was also the
stand-in for king shark aj told
comicbook.com i was tall gun needed
somebody tall like literally needed
somebody tall
when task force act stops by a bar to
grab a few drinks they find a few dozen
other people there with them one however
stands out above the rest there's a man
with white hair seen dancing with
several women though the character is
never given a name the actor playing him
is one of the most important people in
james gunn's career schlock horror
legend lloyd kaufman kaufman is the
founder of troma entertainment best
known for bringing us the toxic avenger
gun's film career started at troma in
the 90s when he co-wrote the screenplay
for tromeo and juliet gunn once tweeted
that troma was a crash course in
everything about making movies from
writing a script casting to location
scouting to production to marketing the
film without lloyd kaufman i certainly
wouldn't have the all-around education i
needed to be a film director gunn has
repaid kaufman by giving his mentor
cameos including the small parts and
guardians of the galaxy kaufman once
told vice that gun put me in all these
movies so far and now he's the number
one guy at the box office like that
titanic guy you know i'm the king of the
world only james would never say that
because he's such a nice guy
the first rat catcher only appears in
two scenes albeit two of the most
emotional scenes in the suicide squad
played by taika ytt ratcatcher is often
spoken of in reverent tones throughout
the film or at least as reverent as
people can be about an ostensible
villain who controls rats like many of
the characters in the suicide squad
ratcher is a reimagining of a low-tier
dc comics villain of the same name the
rat catcher of the comics comes from
gotham city rather than portugal he was
an actual rat catcher by trade before
like seemingly half of gotham city he
turned to crime he also had the ability
to speak with and control rats but his
most valuable ability was his
encyclopedic knowledge of gotham's sewer
system which let him move around the
city with ease he's a much less
vulnerable figure than we see in the
suicide squad check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]